[Music]
Justin Timberlake had this song of this
summer we love that song we love it at
home we probably we've probably been
part of at least a hundred thousand
streaming yeah and it sounds like we'll
be getting more new music from the
superstar very soon
we literally came from the studio
tonight to come to this Q & A like we're
weird and we're going back after this
like there's a ton of music that we're
making right now and and I'm just so
excited about it and and yeah you're
right you do have to rein me in JT
dished on his new tunes at a special
variety AARP screening of his movie
trolls Thursday night in Los Angeles
I don't do high fives slap it boss nope
little slappy make daddy happy fine to
Stowe Justin says he made the movie for
his son Silas it really it affected me
and it influenced me and I felt like I
really wanted to make something that I
could share with him you know and and
I'm very quickly becoming to regret it
because all he wants to do is watch so
to be able to share this with him you
know anytime the song comes on the radio
and then the car any-any says daddy
singing and you're like
think I have something in my eye
[Music]